hello everyone hello everyone and
welcome to today's live broadcast
biofilm diversity and ecology presented
by Matthew fields we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented and sponsored by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning for more
information please go to wwm a bruisin
I'm Christina Jewell of lab ropes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on this ve button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce today's speaker mr. Matthew
fields Melfi fields the professor and
director at the Center for biofilm
engineering at Montana on Montana State
University he previously served as
interim head of the microbiology
department now the department of
microbiology and immunology he had CBS
physiology and ecology lab where his
research is focused on metabolic and
genetic processes of microbes and
biofilms these organisms can be involved
in nitrate content
Asian heavy-metal remediation metal
corrosion and bioenergy production among
other areas here in just doctorate and
microbiology with a minor in
biochemistry and biological engineering
from Cornell University Field Service
master's degree in biological sciences
at Mississippi State University and his
bachelor's degree in biology and
chemistry at Western Kentucky University
fiona has won numerous awards and
journal editor ships including the MSU
award for excellence and the Wylie award
for meritorious research he currently
serves a specialty editor for the
journal frontiers and microbiology an
academic editor for the plus one and he
is research fellow at the National
Center for Genome resources in Santa Fe
New Mexico I will now turn the
presentation over to him mr. Matthew
Peele Thank You Kristina so as Christina
said I'm at the Center for biofilm
engineering at Montana State University
and I wanted to give a quick outline of
the talk that I'll be presenting today
and so one when we when we talk about
biofilm we're talking about microbial
biofilms and so I want to give a quick
synopsis of microorganisms in the role
on the planet and what are biofilms and
what we mean by a biofilm why why do why
do biological systems particularly
microbial biological systems produce
biofilms and why they're important to
study where we find them which is in a
myriad of different environments on the
planet and what do we know thus far on
for microbial biofilms and who's there
in reference to the ecology of those
biofilms and so this this image here
that you're looking at is actually the
campus of Montana State University in
the BOK drought in the backdrop
the Bridger Mountains in Bozeman Montana
so real quick about the Center for
biofilm engineering we're now on our 26
year where originally were funded by the
National Science Foundation as part of
their engineering Research Center
program and our mission is to promote
and conduct interdisciplinary research
and education dealing with biofilm
research and a big tenant of what we do
at the center is to transfer our biofilm
knowledge to help solve industrial
medical and environmental problems and
so we have a tripartite mission of
research education and outreach and a
big part of that outreach is technology
transfer and actually interacting with
industrial companies so as I mentioned
in the outline I want to give a quick
just catch everybody up to speed I know
we have different folks with different
backgrounds and so about microorganisms
and so microorganisms are predicted to
comprise the largest amount of biomass
on the planet and they all played
pivotal roles in ecosystem function and
just about any imaginable planet or any
imaginal environment on the planet is
going to contain microorganisms and
they're going to play a very important
roles in the functioning of that
ecosystem on top of that they represent
an immense as yet undiscovered
biochemical capacities and so we we know
that we've barely scratched the surface
of identifying what microorganisms are
out there what organisms we can
cultivate in the lab and actually have
genome sequence for and so the what we
think we know about microorganisms is
really based on a small percentage of
the ones that we've been able to study
in the lab and we know there's a lot
more out there and there's a lot meaning
that there's a lot to discover and a lot
to learn about about even carbon cycling
nitrogen cycling and phosphorus cycling
and how microbes play a role in that so
a lot of good biochemistry Mikell
organisms as I mentioned dictate global
biogeochemical processes for the cycling
of carbon nitrogen sulfur and phosphorus
for almost every environment on the
planet and actually it's estimated that
microorganisms contain about half of the
organic carbon
planet and the other half being residing
in plants and then they also contain the
majority of organic nitrogen and
phosphorus on earth and so that means
that most of the nitrogen most of
biological nitrogen and phosphorus right
now on the planet resides in microbial
realm at the planet microbes so so in
summary here for this slide
microorganisms play an important role on
the planet and they're very plentiful
and there are lots of different
environments and they do many important
things so this is looking at a tree of
life based on 16s and 18s genes a common
biomarker to compare all the different
types of life-forms on the planet so we
have the three domains bacterial archaea
and Eukarya and when we think about this
this tree of life and all of life as we
know it right now and here's where we
are in the animal in animal kingdom
within the domain of Eukarya and if we
really think that about the this tree of
life and in and what is large
macroscopic organisms and what's
microbial the vast majority of this tree
of life is microbial so this means that
the vast majority of life on the planet
is is microbial they're microorganisms
irrespective if you're thinking about
that about the domain bacteria or
archaea or Eukarya when we think about
multicellular large animals or really at
the rat we're at a minority when we
think about the Tree of Life
and so this states that most of life on
the planet is microbial and most of that
life probably exists as biofilm and so
typically this is thought of is
sometimes you'll see this referred to as
a mode of attached growth and so when
you think about a biological organism
and it's going to attach to a surface
that's going to be synonymous with this
term biofilm and within what's typically
the paradigm in biology right now is
that most of this microbial life is
existing in a biofilm mode or as
on a life of a form of life that's going
to be attached to a surface and so by
this attached node what we mean is is
that microorganisms exist to self
organize communities attached to
surfaces and to one another and they're
going to be surrounded by a
self-produced extracellular polymeric
substance that can contain a wide
variety of biological and non-biological
compounds and so by non-biological
compounds I'm meaning anything that's
kind of any sort of chemistry or
chemicals or anions or cations that are
going to be present in that environment
and by biological compounds of meaning
certainly cells but anything than any
type of macromolecule it's going to be
produced by those cells via protein
lipids carbohydrate polymers thereof or
nucleic acids and so there's going to be
this they're basically a self-organized
community that have lots of different
microbial populations in it and they're
going to be sort of surrounded in this
matrix that's made up of lots of
different biological compounds and so
then this this term or this phrase
attached mode really is synonymous with
the biofilm and this biofilm then is is
is just what I had stated as a
self-organized community and it's sort
of on a surface now by surface we can
think of these these phase boundaries in
a variety of states and so when I think
about a surface it could be between a
liquid and a solid it can be between a
liquid and a gas or it can be between a
solid and a solid it's really any type
of phase boundary where there's gonna be
moisture and there's going to be
nutrients involved you're going to find
microbial biofilms in that type of
environment and they're going to be a
multitude of physical chemical
conditions if we can think about all the
different types of environments on the
planet that are going to be able to have
these phase boundaries between solid
liquid and gas and even looking back
into the fossil record it's been
reported in the literature that actually
we we have remnants of what looked like
microbial biofilms all the way back to
three-and-a-half billion years ago and
so these are evolutionarily ancient
forms of microbial life that probably
play a role in the evolution
of life itself and even today it's
usually estimated that the vast majority
of microbial populations that are
present exist in a biofilm state some
type of a state where they're they're
attached either to each other brought to
a liquid or a solid surface between
these phase boundaries so then by by
definition and there are lots of working
definitions for what a biofilm is and
this is one that we typically use at the
centre but there will be certainly
others and you can there are variations
of these definitions but as I stated
it's it's a group of microorganisms
living in a self-organized community
attached to surfaces or interfaces or
each other or all the above and they're
embedded in a matrix of extracellular
polymeric substances that they've made
themselves and they exhibit altered
phenotypes and behavior compared to free
living planktonic cells and so by free
living planktonic cells I mean organisms
growing in a free in a suspension in a
liquid how we usually grow them in the
lab and so those that type of
environment is going to be very
different when we think about this
notion of cells sort of coming together
and aggregating together and then living
at these phase boundaries we're starting
more and more we're seeing that the that
that type of biological system has a
very type are very different type of
phenotype and behavior in these images
then and I'll hit some of these in the
next couple slides or examples of how we
can think about biofilm and this image
on the bottom is actually a confocal
image that was taken at the center that
shows that the 3d structure of this
biofilm and so they can be very large
they can be small they're going to scale
they're going to have large-scale
variation and different sizes that
dependent upon the organisms that are
present and the types of environments
that they find themselves in
so this is an example of a different
type of confocal microscope image and
it's sort of signifying a multi-species
environmental biofilm and so a lot of
the times we go into the environment
these bio at these microbial biofilms
are going to have lots of different
organisms in them lots of different
morphologies and we can stain them in
different ways to sort of highlight the
diversity that were within this biofilm
this is a biofilm that's been staying
with a red green fluorescent DNA stain
so any intact cells then they're going
to have DNA are going to be able to
fluoresce with this stain in the field
of view here is a 250 square kilometer
250 square millimeters at 630 times
magnification now in in comparison this
is a confocal image where you can see
it's actually a monoculture it's a
single species of an organism
Pseudomonas aeruginosa this is a common
soil and water bacterium but it can also
be found in the human environment and
this is a typical type of biofilm that
you would get from a Pseudomonas
bacterium that shows again you sort of
have these this low-lying flat area and
then you get these mushroom or haystack
like structures that that sort of come
up out of the horizontal plane of the
biofilm and you can then use this
confocal imaging to get the 3d
dimensions of a biofilm like this and
again this is at 250 square millimeters
at 630 magnification so this the next
two graphics will sort of depict the
formation of biofilm in the transition
states but behind how a biofilm forms
and so at some point you're going to
have to have a surface and this let me
come down here and so if you look down
here you're going to have some type of
phase boundary between a liquid and a
solid state and you're going to have
microorganisms that are in this
planktonic state they're in the bulk
phase of that liquid and they're going
to come into contact with that surface
and they're going to colonize it and at
which point and you can already start to
see a difference in these cells at this
point they're being shown to have these
flagellar structures and
motile and they're thought to come into
contact with the solid surface at which
point they're going to typically or at
least the based on the systems that are
typically studied for biofilm formation
those structures and motility are lost
or altered and they start to chip to
build produce different types of
cellular structures that are going to
allow them to become sessile to stay in
place and interact with the surface and
interact with each other and during that
process then they start to accumulate
this what starts to be an initial
biofilm and they start producing this
matrix that's going to start to encase
the biofilm cells are going to start to
divide and they're going to build more
matrix they're going to change the
proteins and the carbohydrates and
lipids that they're producing in this
biofilm then is going to start to
communicate with one another and it and
this can be either for a monoculture
biofilm or for a mixed species biofilm
at which point then they're going to
start to form what's called these micro
colonies and that and this is going to
be driven by then cell division of the
different cells and you can imagine that
as this biofilm grows and this the cell
number increases the matrix that's
encasing these cells starts to increase
you're going to start to get chemical
gradients that form meaning that
whatever type of mass transport from the
bulk phase that the cells are going to
need and whatever thus waste products
the cells are going to have inside the
biofilm and they need to get out there's
going to be gradients that are going to
start to form in the button the the
cells are going to start to respond
physiologically to those gradients that
form in the biofilm and so in essence
when you when you finally get to this
stage it's being seen here and what
we're gonna have is a as a mature
biofilm there's going to be what are
considered micro niches and that's being
shown here by these different colors
you're gonna have different organisms
within this biofilm that that's going to
show heterogeneity these different cell
types are going to be doing different
things and they're going to be
responding to the gradients of things
coming in and things coming out
- where ultimately you what you what you
we would get something that that's being
depicted here as this mature biofilm and
so the the biofilm has grown it's
reached a somewhat steady state with
mass transport of nutrients from the
outside and nutrient in the waste
products coming out and it's going to
start to be lit go cells and this is
what's called seeding dispersal and so
cells are actually going to be start to
be released and those cells that are
going to go and colonize and a new
environment and start a new biofilm this
can also be another way that this can
happen is through this these structures
up here at the top of the screen biofilm
streamers or that you'll actually get
these dislodging of these large
aggregates that can go and move to
different places in the environment and
initiate new biofilm but ultimately keep
in mind that when we during the
formation of this biofilm in reaching
the state of a mature biofilm there's a
lot of heterogeneity within this biofilm
and so almost start to imagine that what
we typically think of for microbes as
being single celled organisms they can
form these biofilms and in essence
become multicellular macroscopic and so
I think this was this has ramifications
for when we think about the evolution of
biological systems I mentioned that the
center the for biofilm engineering where
I'm located is a very interdisciplinary
research center and that's because of
the the heterogeneity of what a biofilm
is so because of the micro niches that
are forming this biofilm and the
chemical and the biological gradients
you can imagine that you have to have
experts in microbial ecology microbial
physiology microbial genetics genomics
and biochemistry as well as as engineers
that understand flow transport
environmental engineering and civil
engineering and biological and chemical
engineering as well as for any but like
as with any biological system
bioinformatics and statistics and so you
sort of need expertise in all of these
areas or individuals that are experts in
different areas to really start to
tackle what biofilm is so I hope I've
described what what biofilm is but why
why biofilm and I can think of this
question in two ways
why do microbes exist as biofilm would
be the first question and so we know
microbes are important on the planet we
know that my most microbes are going to
exist as biofilm we know that biofilms
or our self-organized microbial
communities that exist at interfaces and
they encapsulate and encapsulate
themselves in a self-made matrix but why
do that and so if we take a step back
and think about most microbial
environments these are physically
dynamic environments where fluxes and
water and nutrients and temperature and
pH osmolarity think about any sort of
geochemical or geophysical constraints
that the system is going to have
inherent to it and the microorganisms
are going to have to respond to that in
a big one in this is dehydration and so
we know that dehydration events or water
limitation events can inhibit motility
they limit nutrient availability and in
essence they can have a big impact on
microbial activity and so biofilm was
probably at least one answer to that
type of limitation and so we know
biofilms can help retain water
they sort of nutrients they protect
against salinity and osmolarity changes
and pH changes and nutrient availability
and redox potentials and so in many ways
these geo chemical and geophysical
constraints the biofilm is a way to
respond to those constraints in addition
we know that biofilms can be protection
against predation and so this would be
again there's a lot of micro eukaryotes
that actually are predators for bacteria
and so there's actually protection
against predation in within biofilm and
we can actually even think about this in
the human system and actually is
protection against immune cells and so
you have an immune system that can
elicit response to the presence of
microorganisms and there is some
protection when they are in this biofilm
mode
so that would be thinking about why by
why microbes exist as biofilms this
would be this would be multiple answers
to that question we also know that
biofilms are an evolutionary adaptation
to changing environments and so this was
probably one reason why they are
evolutionarily ancient answer to the
context of constraints that biological
systems can experience and in fact
there's been some recent work to suggest
that we can think about these systems
even where cooperation and
differentiation were likely forged and
selected we know that again in the
fossil record we know that that things
that look like extinct microbial
biofilms existed on early Earth and this
was probably a way for biological
systems to forge this ability to
cooperate with one another and get
selected for it and then in another
recent paper by Hooper amber Stein they
posited actually that the minimization
of extracellular space in a microbial
biofilm particularly ones that contained
both bacteria and archaea probably
promoted cellular associations that
impacted the metabolism of this overall
the overall metabolism of the biofilm
and may have even contributed to the
evolution of Eukarya itself and so these
are some very interesting arguments for
thinking about the role that biofilms
played in the evolution of eukaryotes
and so another question what that could
be
in reference to why biofilm is why
should we study biofilm and I hope I've
gone through and and what I'm going to
try to do then in the next sets of
slides is to sort of show that because
microbes are important on the planet
most of those microbes exist as biofilm
we should be understood be studying them
and understanding them when they're in
that biofilm growth mode and so this has
very large impacts on both applied and
fundamental microbiology as well as
synthetic biology and even thinking
about in general how biological systems
evolved to particular constraints the
the groundwork for all of this was being
laid laid down a long time ago and
there's a lot that we have to learn
about how biological systems behave and
how they respond to constraints of the
system
and so the the title of the talk was
diversity in ecology and so part of that
is you know where do we find these
biofilms and and what and who who who
makes up what organisms make up these
biofilms and so as I stated microbial
biofilms are present and almost all
known microbial habitats that includes
the human body and we're getting an
increasingly we're getting an increasing
appreciation of the role that these
microbes are playing on the human body
and they exist as multi species
communities that with extreme complexity
and so again we cannot think about
microbes as the single celled simple
single-celled organisms because they
they have the ability to form these
multicellular macroscopic structures
that have very different types of
behavior than what we think of as a
single cell so where where are biofilms
and so some of the most studied habitats
range from wastewater treatment to
drinking water to marine surface water
to industrial light installations any
type of industrial processing plant and
such is going to have microbes a part of
that ecosystem hospitals rhizosphere
agricultural fields mine water
subsurface soils
it's lots of different environments and
this is just this certainly as an
all-inclusive as only naming examples of
some of the better studied systems and
then we can go all the way to the human
centric environments that include oral
intestinal skin.your in area in
respiratory systems and and I'll sort of
round out the talk with with thinking
about how the microbiome has impacted
our our understanding of microbial
biofilms in the human on and in the
human body and so the investigation of
biofilm structure and composition is
well justified and few other topics have
as far-reaching implications for the
challenges that face human society and
the really to me the four big ones being
water food energy and health so water is
going to involve microbes in microbial
biofilms and how we process wastewater
how to clean it and how weakly part how
we keep our our potable water clean
certainly with food and thinking about
nitrogen fixation and climate change and
carbon fixation and fertilizers and how
we process that fertilizer go back to
the point that I raised about the
majority of my biological nitrogen and
phosphorus on the planet is is retained
within the Mike
a world we need that nitrogen and
phosphorus to grow more food and so
that's got to have a big impact the
contribution of microbial biofilms there
is going to be big energy certainly
thinking about our consumption of
subsurface energy as well as making
bioenergy and alternative energy is
biofilms are going to play a role and as
I mentioned in the mic the micro biomes
and the human health and the roles that
the microbes are playing in that arena
as well so I'm going to give this a
smattering of some examples of this and
so in them in the medical arena I'll go
through these examples here we can think
about chronic wounds for instance a
diabetic ulcer patient is going to have
a chronic wound that won't heal and some
of some work that we do and it's a
heavily researched area across the world
what this is a this is thought of as a
biofilm that's established in that
chronic wound and how its interacting
with the host cells how it controls the
movement of plasma and nutrients and
oxygen content and why is that wound not
healing this would be an example say of
a chronic ulcer or wound on a foot that
would be very common common in a
diabetic patient certainly moving over
here to the right thinking about the
human oral cavity and the growth of
dental plaque and gingivitis and dental
caries and the role that microorganisms
play in that environment and it's
actually one of the most most studied
microbial or ecological area one the
most studied microbial environment
studied in respect to ecology and where
we have a really good understanding of
what's going on but there's still a lot
that we don't know then this this
graphic here down on the lower left is
sort of giving an example of different
environments that are studied around the
world and how microbial biofilms can
impact catheters at different systems
say artificial implants into the human
body even in the mouth where we have an
interface between a solid surface like
the tooth enamel and liquid that's
coming over that tooth enamel these are
all what I meant by phase boundaries and
these are great habitats that are going
to be
in environments for my groups to live
contact lens is another example of this
phase boundary of a solid surface that's
going to be between where you're going
to have liquid in between and you've got
to the surface of the eye and the
surface of the contact lens and then the
liquid in between if these aren't kept
clean or if these aren't replaced right
or if you get a solution that's
contaminated this is a great place for
biofilms to grow this is looking at a
different type of a wound where in this
human body where we have a wound that
won't heal and what's the role of
biofilm and why it's not allowing the
body to heal and then again as I
mentioned surgical implants and this is
another area of research and
understanding my unwanted microbial
biofilms we can move into surfaces
around the home where some are obvious
say in the bathroom or in hot tubs or in
other moist environments like a shower
stall into the kitchen but even then
thinking about these surfaces of say a
carpet and where you don't really think
of them as a moist environment but there
certainly is enough moisture for
microbes to grow and there's a lot of
work than trying to understand microbial
biofilms in these types of environments
and I want to this is a good point to
raise we typically think of a microbial
biofilm is a big snotty slimy structure
and it doesn't always have to be that
way and so even when we think about an
environment like this this carpet that's
being shown down in the lower right hand
corner and that maybe we don't think of
as a lot of free moisture in that there
is moisture and particles of food and
other debris that come into that
environment and you're going to get
microbes then growing on those surfaces
and adhering to them and so these these
in fact do become environments from
microbial biofilms we can think of a
wide array of natural environments and
man-made structures that become home to
microbial biofilms and so up here on the
upper left and lower lower left we can
think about natural stream environments
or where there's water we have photo
photo driven types of environments all
the way to the thermal features within
Yellowstone and the different types of
mat material we have those are those are
technically biofilms we can think of
water cooling towers and industry or why
water water cooling after a die where
we're going to get liquid and solid
interfaces and there's going to be food
there for microbial biofilms to
establish this example up here are
actually water lines from a dental
office and if you then take that tubing
out so these would be potable water
distribution lines and you get
formations of biofilm on on the inside
of these this is an example of a kitchen
drain sink obviously lots of different
types of nutrients that are going to be
coming through that environment and the
types of biofilm that can establish this
would be an example of a metal pipe or
think of these commonly is in water and
oil and gas distribution systems and a
large problem is metal corrosion and bio
microbial biofilms play a big role in
that food processed food and food
processing surfaces are another big area
and I think it's going to be one that's
going to really start to grow as we try
to control foodborne pathogens and how
food is processed and in an industrial
setting in this industrial setting is
being shown here how can we control
microbial biofilms there's an examples
of household biofilms and so this would
be something that almost any of us can
relate to this would be of a kitchen
sink and we can then move down and then
we use a stereomicroscope at the center
and you can start to see then the
biofilm that's going to be the biofilm
that's going to be underneath this drain
within between the rubber stopper you've
got lots of moisture coming flew through
lots of food and the establishment of a
biofilm this was in being an example of
an aerator that's in the faucet a
kitchen sink faucet and microbes are
going to start to establish and growth
or start to establish and grow biofilm
this would be say a common kitchen sink
sponge and the types of microbial
biofilm is grown within that sponge and
then here's a toothbrush and you can
look down at the base of that toothbrush
and you start to see microbial biofilm
growth or then even look at the base of
these bristles here and you can start to
then see microbial biofilm growth and
and it's gonna happen and how do we then
understand the events that are leading
to this growth and how can we control it
so I want to go through that some
different examples of where we find find
biofilm and what do we know about the
ecology these biofilms and I'm not going
to go into microbial mount mats except
for this one slide and I wanted to
mention microbial mats because they are
a very well studied system and
technically it's a biofilm it's just
going to be a much larger type of
biofilm and so these are evolutionarily
ancient biofilms these are the types of
biofilms that probably we find fossil
record for on ancient earth they're
vertically stratified laterally
compressed with different trophic groups
of bacteria B along these geochemical
boundaries or geophysical boundaries and
how they establish themselves so this is
an example of a microbial mat this is
very large as you can see and where you
have photo tropes in the top and then
you get probably fermentation and we get
to more anaerobic metabolism and
ultimately to sulfate reducers and iron
reducers and so this is a great example
of a macroscopic microbial biofilm and
so we don't have to think of them as
hard to see or big big slimy types of
structures that only can be grown in the
lab we can go out to the national
natural world and find examples of these
microbial biofilms and there's a lot to
learn about how biology evolved in
processing nutrients and cycling
nutrients I also wanted to mention algal
fungal biofilms and so this is a growing
area within the biofilm research area
and so we know that that algal fungal
biofilms are prevalent and important and
lots of different natural and man-made
environments and in fact some recent
work has shown and actually recent work
actually back in the 90s has actually
estimated that almost 20% of fungi are
able to form symbiotic relationships
with algae and things known as lichens
and so most people are familiar with
lichens and so almost 20% of fungi are
and these types of relationships and
this is actually could be considered as
an algal
well biofilm and we know that they play
very important roles in nutrient
turnover as well as maintenance of
biodiversity in lots of different
environments so this is work from recent
publication in 2016 where you are
starting to actually grow chlorella
which is an algae and this Mook or
fungus and understanding how they
interact and grow as a biofilm and the
nice life down here at the bottom is
work from the USGS where they want to
understand these photo photo driven
algal biofilms that you're going to see
prevalent in lots of aquatic
environments and actually try to find
ways to grow them in a lab in a
tractable way to understand nutrient
turnover in a mixed eukaryotic biofilm
this also leads them to this notion of
exterior biofilms and by exterior or
really meaning sort of exterior man-made
structures and so we know that these
types of structures are going to be
inhabited by bacteria algae and fungi
and they can cause aesthetic as well as
physical damage but they also can
contribute to health issues and so
there's a lot of work or I should say a
lot of upcoming work about the built
environment on the outside and the
interior of the of the building and how
mixed microbial biofilms play a role in
that environment so this was a recent
paper that I'm citing here in 2014 where
and they looked at different
cyanobacteria populations that were
predominating building facades in India
and actually a few years ago then
there's some work done by Polo at all
which is some some work that we have
some we have there's a colleagues of
ours in Italy and they've been looking
at this notion or this ability of green
algae and black fungi to dominate
biofilms on motor mortar and stone
buildings and they actually found that
the mortar used for restoration of these
ancient or historically relevant
buildings the the rest of compound
that's used contains acrylic and
siloxane and that these actually turn
turn out to be used as carbon and energy
sources for the microorganisms and
actually help grow the biofilm and I put
this picture here at the Jefferson
Memorial there's been some recent news
in the
news articles on the web and by the
Washington Post where they're interested
in some of this fungal algal biofilm
that's actually starting to deteriorate
the Jefferson Memorial so this would be
another place another important role
that detrimental role that that mixed
species biofilms are playing in man-made
environments now we also have
environments in the subsurface if you
can imagine the even the top kilometer
of the Earth's crust and think of that
as the subsurface of the soil
there's a lot of microbial biomass there
and those microbes are adhere to the
surf the soil as a biofilm and there
there's a lot of interest in
understanding what they do and what role
they play and carbon turnover for the
for the planet though what I mentioned
in here now is and what I'm showing is
subsurface biofilms and energy because
in my lab we study coal bed methane and
we know that there are coal seams deep
coal seams and that they produce natural
gas and a significant portion of that
natural gas is actually being actively
made by a microbial pop by a microbial
community actually and we know that
what's happening is that microbial
community is interacting with the coal
and actually adhering to it and using
that as a carbon source that ultimately
gets broken down into natural gas and
then energy companies harvest the water
out of the ground they collect that
natural gas and they can sell it as an
energy source and so we've been
interested actually in in the subsurface
coal biofilms and creating a field site
in eastern Montana in conjunction with
the USGS to understand the distribution
of these coal biofilms at different
levels and so just to give an example of
this is the type of work that you have
to go out at these field sites you have
wells in the ground and we can pump
water and then we can put down samplers
into these wells and allow the
microorganisms to in essence and habit
the coal and form biofilms on that coal
so that we could then bring them back up
to the surface and study them so these
are just examples of graduate students
at our field site outside of Boerne
Montana and this is actually water
being collected as we pump it out of
those wells and all of that bubble all
those bubbles are actually the methane
gas that's being produced by
microorganisms and so we can we can
drill so as being shown here in this
slide at our field site these are
showing different wells and these wells
go to different depths and when we
develop those wells then we have the
core material and out of these coal
materials out of these core materials we
can then assess microbial communities as
they're distributed through this
material and you can then see this this
would be an example the mixing from a
sandstone into the coal material and we
can ask when did the bio what are the
microbial biofilm communities look like
on that coal material and we can
actually then start to assess which
populations are being predominating at
with coal material and which microbial
populations are more common in the in
the sandstone areas and so with the with
the idea that we want to understand what
microbes are present with that coal how
are they degrading that coal and how
does that impact the overall ability of
methanogens --ss and so in essence we're
we're looking at subsurface microbial
biofilms how they turn over recalcitrant
carbon in the terrestrial subsurface and
how this ultimately then links in with
the global carbon cycle another area
that microbial biofilms are very
important are and I as I mentioned is
this and one of the previous slides that
picture of the corroding metal pipeline
and so metal corrosion is is very big
problem particularly in water
distribution and gas distribution and
petroleum hydrocarbon distribution and
so corrosion is a relatively simple
electrochemical process that involves
matching electro chemicals processes
between the oxidation of a metal at the
anode and a parallel chemical reduction
at the cathode and microorganisms
actually help complete the circuit and
carry out metal corrosion and so we know
that microbial biofilms can actually
help accelerate the corrosion process
and in some instances they can actually
help [ __ ] it by actually covering and
protecting the metal from sort of from
chemical chemical redox addition or
source a chemical read
reactions so this is an image from a
review paper that was written by Dennis
anything at all in 2012 and this go back
and get my marker so this material here
is the microbial biofilm and these are
microbial cells and so what's happening
is that they actually will get organic
carbon and electron sources from the
bulk phase they can also then strip that
out of the metal surface and in this
case we're showing sulfate reducers and
so they'll take those electrons and
reduce sulfate to sulfide which itself
is a corrosive agent and this can also
then produce iron sulphides then that
reside on the metal and so this this
microbial process then is helping to eat
away at the metal surface actually
millimeters per year and that can play a
very strong role in corroding and
finally having pipeline failure this is
this is a SEM image of actual metal
surface where we grow metal biofilms and
these are the start to be the corrosive
pits that these microbes will form now a
lot of the times sulfate-reducing
bacteria been typically been studied as
culprits in this but through microbial
ecology these biofilms were finding out
that there's also Actinobacteria back
toward eddies firma qts Proteobacteria
as well as other sulfate-reducing
bacteria sulfide oxidizing bacteria as
well as methanogens are starting to
appreciate the diversity of the
different microbes in these biofilms and
the role they play in microbial
corrosion this is an example of some
work that we've done at the Center for
biofilm engineering where we took an
sulfate-reducing bacteria and grew it
under different nutrient conditions
these are actually biofilms on metal
surfaces and you can start to see the
formation of these of these different
minerals and so what type of biofilm and
I should say that the conditions that
the biofilm has grown under will dictate
the amount of corrosion and the types of
mineral precipitates that are being
formed we can and when I say two
different amounts of corrosion we can
actually use a potentia stat and poised
these metal surfaces and get a
measurement of electrical current and we
know that under certain conditions we
can actually increase metal corrosion
and in other conditions a different
points in time we can have a decrease in
the corrosion we've also been this graph
here is in conjunction or in
collaboration with Gary's used act at
the Scripps Institute Laurie been out
been applying metabolomics to try to
understand what are the different
chemical metabolites in these biofilms
and how do they contribute to the
overall corrosion rate I mentioned in an
earlier slide that biofilms are
important for wastewater treatment this
has been a this has had a huge impact on
humans on human society in the last
hundred or so years on our ability to
treat our wastewater and clean it up and
so biofilm is very important in that and
so typically in the wastewater
environment you would see this referred
to as flocks or granules or aggregates
these are in essence types of biofilms
and we have mixed species in these
biofilms that are very essential to turn
over the organic wastes and reference to
the organic carbon the nitrogen and the
phosphorus that's there and so
ultimately municipal water can be
treated and then can be released back
into the environment so there's been
this is a there's been a lot of work in
this area to understand how how microbes
are interacting to carry out this
process that we're interested in at a
philo level or a subphyla level we know
that beta proteobacteria are seen are
observed commonly as well as Bacteroides
is it a seto bacterium Cora flexi as
well as then these in this particular
review by these authors this year
highlighting these different microbial
groups of play important roles in
wastewater treatment and then this ESCO
miqo'te is actually a eukaryote that's
involved in interacting with these
different microbes for wastewater
treatment and one thing that's been
interesting in these different papers
that have come out and I'm trying to
understand biofilm is is that we're
seeing that biofilm structures are
actually related to the treatment
process and so depending upon what type
of biofilm is there in the treatment
facility there's lots of different ways
to treat wastewater and there's
different stages of wastewater treatment
as you can see down here in this typical
wastewater treatment facility if we're
starting to see that the biofilm is
present in the microbes that are present
in that biofilm is going to have a big
impact on the
treatment process and how well the
carbon and the nitrogen and phosphorus
are treated this means that as we learn
how to control the ecology we're gonna
be able to control the process better
we're going to be able to make it more
stable and more efficient and actually
ultimately get the desired new Trojans I
claim that we want it so this is another
big area of biofilm research is in the
wastewater treatment area so this is an
example of some of the work that we've
been doing in the wastewater area and so
I have a graduate student that's been
looking at the wastewater Lagoon system
at in Logan Utah this is one of the
largest municipal wastewater lagoons in
the country it's 460 acres and holds
about 900 million gallons of water and
so for reference of these wastewater
Lagoon systems this the bottom here is
being shown in that it's one mile in
length and that what what this diagram
is showing is that here is where the
influent comes into the wastewater
lagoons it moves into these two ponds
which then moves into its respective B
they those to come into C and then into
D and the new E and this is where the
the effluent is and ultimately when you
have water down here is where you want
to have a low organic carbon low
nitrogen and low phosphorous so that
water can be released into the
environment and so we were curious then
on what does the at the biofilm ecology
or the aggregates look like in these
different ponds as we move between
through the lagoon different ponds in
that system and we actually were able to
to track bacterial diversity or kale
diversity and that bacteria are kale
Eukarya and actually the double stranded
viruses that that infect the algal
component of that community and so we
know for instance that the algal
diversity remains low and shows the
least amount of variation over time and
I should mention that when we sampled
these ponds we were in the surface water
and so this isn't surprising because I
think most of the algal diversity will
probably be in the sediments that are
settling at the bottom of that of those
lagoon systems we know that the
eukaryote diversity demonstrated a
little fluctuation but through the ponds
but it has higher diversity
depending upon what pawn system you're
in and so this probably has something to
do with the flux of nutrient in those in
those particular ponds we know that
bacterial diversity fluctuates way more
it actually was highest in particular
pond B D and E and these are actually
some of the ponds where we have the
lowest eukaryote diversity and so this
starts to give you some insight into
potential competition between very high
level microbial groups that are fighting
for that for those nutrients that you
want to turn over and ultimately we had
the highest diversity measures in
variation in the double-stranded DNA
viruses particularly the ones that
impacted by our algae and so what we're
trying to do is now is take all of that
data and estimate create create or
estimate a food network these are
basically population networks that where
we're trying to understand positive and
negative correlations or interactions
between different microbial groups
within these aggregates and biofilms and
what how do they impact nutrient
recycling in this given environment and
this is very common line of work that's
that's in wastewater treatment right now
another environment is groundwater
biofilms and this is another area that
we look at trying to understand how how
biofilms on these sediments are impacted
by groundwater as they move through a
very large landscape scale and so this
is an example of where we drop sediment
samples into these wells so that we can
then get an idea of the groundwater
flowing through these and how biofilms
that form on those sediments compare
between those that environment and the
water and the water that's actually
moving through and trying to identify
again particular populations that are
enriched in these different environments
and relate that into the activity that
they're carrying out in that environment
this is a common back to water this is a
work that was done in 2014 and
understanding the formation of water
that's in premise plumbing this is the
plumbing that's moving drinking water in
houses and how in this paper they
compared on plasticized PVC to actually
copper piping and how that microbial
biofilms were different and then how
those biofilms responded to the
introduction of a particular pathogen
say like Legionella and so this is an
area of work and
they found was that different material
had different drinking water biofilms
but there both were able to resist the
infection of Legionella which then will
help us build better materials for and
understand premise plumbing and how we
move drinking water around this is
another area of research than this paper
was done in 2009 and showerhead biofilms
and they actually found particular
microbes that were inhabiting these
these biofilms of interest was the the
identification of micro species bacteria
which have been related to pulmonary
disease and whether you have municipal
drinking water or if you're on well
water they found the incidence of these
micro bacteria different so that's
another active area of research this was
another interesting paper of Flores 2013
where they were actually tracking
biofilms in the different kitchen
environments and ultimately they found
that the human skin was the primary
source for all surfaces with some
contamination of food and the fossil
faucet water as you would suspect and so
thinking about then all the different
surfaces in an environment like the
kitchen and how we interact with that
environment and interchange microbial
biofilms between between those
environments so I'm going to wrap up
then thinking about the human microbiome
which has been an active area of
research and thinking about microbial
biofilms whether we're talking about the
stomach or the intestines or the mouth
or the skin so this was an interesting
work that came out this year of looking
at dental plaque and trying to identify
healthy organ are individuals with swirl
and healthy oral activity and ones that
were more in a disease state and they
could identify then these these
microbial populations with healthy
individuals and then more in an
unhealthy state poor feminists Tanner
Elia Treponema a new bacterium human
skin is another active area of
understanding biofilm growth and we can
we can think of the human body in the
largest organ being one and a half to
two meters square square meters of
surface area and all the microbes that
are on that and what your xiulet shown
here is 3d imaging of individual body
spots and looking at the distribution of
Staphylococcus Propionibacterium and
cornea bacterium
and the prevalence of those microbial
populations at different spots in the
human body and that and again that paper
came out last year in 2015 and then the
the role that those organisms play in in
maintaining healthy skin and in disease
states of the skin this is an active
area of research and could be considered
biofilm and then lastly the one of the
more actively studied areas and the
human body is the obviously the
intestinal biofilm
we know that there's over a thousand
microbial species there dominated by
these five micro bacterial phyla with
some archaea mainly methanogens and you
carry out being driven by yeast we know
that the number of genes contained in
the gut microflora greatly outnumbers
even the genes in our own genome we know
that these these intestinal biofilms
help facilitate nutrients they set the
size vitamins they stimulate the immune
system they maintain low numbers of
pathogens there's been some work to show
that there's a link between irritable
bowel syndrome obesity diabetes are
Tilles grossest and colorectal cancel
and so for example into those 2015 I
actually talked about this for instance
this one organism that's a moose
integrator and that it develops specific
interactions with host cells and in a
mouse study it actually protected the
host from a diet induced obesity and so
mucin is the there's that the slime is
produced by intestinal cells and how my
groups interact with that and the role
that that plays in and overall health of
the individual and so with that I want
to wrap up and hopefully gave a breadth
of different places we find biofilms why
biofilm is important and what do we know
thus far about who's in those biofilms
this is a picture of a lot of the folks
at the center so again as I mentioned
we're an interdisciplinary research
center with lots of different experts in
different areas and then this is my
research group and work in my lab is
currently funded by the Department of
Energy the NSF and NIH thank you very
much
Thank You dr. Matthew fields for that
informative presentation it's now time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. fields please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the fed button we will answer as many
questions that we have time for now
let's get started our first question is
dr. Fields when different bio film
communities encounter each other does
anything happen at the interphase great
question oh okay and so that's a great
question it's probably one that we don't
have a lot of information on we do know
that there's a lot of communication
between populations within a bio film
and so I think the same would hold true
for a given intact bio film as an
in-court as it came into contact with
another bio film I think there's going
to be lots of interaction and
communication and we can think about
that as potential cooperation and and
potential competition and how and so
there's a lot of active areas of
research trying to understand those
interactions and yes I think it would
and so the second part of that question
is or no I think hopefully that answers
that question
I think hopefully that answers that
next question do different bacterial
strains generate different types of
biofilm and if so does its intact the
stability of the biofilm yes definitely
different bacterial strains generate
different types of biofilm they biofilms
will differ depending upon what organism
they are what genus or species or even
the strain as you mentioned they will be
very tight small biofilms we get very
big thick biofilms it's a net that
really is dependent upon the population
or populations that makes up that
biofilm and what they're actively eating
and the nutrients they have available to
them and then so the second part of your
question was about stability and
definitely that will impact stability
different microbes make different types
of structures that they use to sort of
fortify and strengthen that biofilm
matrix and and how they interact in it
and so yes it will definitely impact the
stability of that as well
next question how in your sample and
study the different micro environments
present in mature biofilms particularly
multi species biofilms so so there are
definitely micro environments within
within the biofilm and work that's being
done right now is to try to actually use
micro electrodes and so these are tiny
electrode electrodes it's a try to
measure different chemical constituents
may be may be redox may be pH and to try
to understand this very heterogeneous
biofilm matrix at a very micro you know
say 10 micron scale what that's how we
sort of get at measuring an intact
biofilm start to pick apart those micro
those micro niches when we think about
multi species biofilms yes then and even
even for a monoculture biofilm this is a
biofilm made by one organism say it's
like Pseudomonas that I showed in my
talk there will probably even be micro
niches and heterogeneity within that
monoculture biofilm meaning I could have
a population of Pseudomonas cells over
here that are doing one thing and they
can pop a subpopulation of Pseudomonas
cells over here they're doing something
very different and so even even within a
monoculture and certainly within a multi
species biofilm then you try to then use
micro electrodes and get at these
different micro niches you can start to
do things like fluorescent and situated
ization that targets different ribosomal
RNA genes or different mRNA genes to get
at subpopulations within that biofilm
and then people are trying to develop
flow cytometry and actually micro same
micro droplet technology where we can
get that biofilm and actually get
individual cells picked out of it and
they ask how what are those different
cells who are they and what are they
doing and how does that contribute to
the heterogeneity that's that we find in
the biofilm
dr. field you know in a laboratory why
do some sugar let me rephrase this in
laboratory why is some sugar induced
biofilm formation by others what so why
some sugars would induce biofilm
formation others won't I think a lot of
that works probably been done on us on a
hand on certain bacteria particularly
pathogens I think what happens is is
that some sugars promote more capsular
material and so that capsular material
helps the helps contribute to the
overall matrix of the biofilm and so
maybe some sugars promote the production
of a capsule while others don't it might
have something to do with different
sugars are actually utilized by
different microorganisms some may not be
utilized at all and so whether you have
growth or not would dictate whether you
have biofilm or not it might also have
something to do with say if we're
talking about gram-negative bacteria
with an LPS and depending upon what
sugars are being produced an organism
might modify the sugars that they're
putting on the ends of their of their
LPS and that might have a that might
have an impact on their ability to
interact with each other and interact
with certain surfaces so that would be
my my first my first guess at that
question next question have any biofilms
been discovered in the nuclear industry
so I'd have to go out of the literature
and look as far as in connected to the
nuclear energy I can say that one area
of the work that we study when I
mentioned the groundwater and subsurface
micro subsurface biofilms is
understanding uranium contamination and
so this was uranium waste from the
Manhattan Project and that's a obviously
long term stored waste and that we have
to deal with the movement of those heavy
metals and we're trying to find ways to
use microorganisms to mediate that
bioremediation project I think if you
went into the nuclear industry on
cooling towers and cooling water you
would definitely find probably biofilm
issues for heat transfer and how about
microbial biofilms are impacting that
and so I think that would be another
area that would impact the nuclear
industry we have time for one more
question as you noted in your
introduction biofilms can form on biotic
as well as abiotic surfaces how do you
model or grow in the lab biofilms that
typically grow on biotic surfaces for an
example of teeth for the human colon so
two examples that I can think of
particularly the ones that you mentioned
teeth would be a great example of a
biological solid surface and so some
people have actually used real teeth to
grow biofilms on but probably what even
more commonly we can use a apatite or
other types of hard material that has a
very similar mineral structure to say
enamel and dentine and actually put make
a thin sheet of that type of material
and then grill biofilm and reactors on
that type of material and another
example that you mentioned was say like
on the intestinal cells and so there has
been growing work to actually grow
this is a new developing area of you can
differentiate a human cell say a human
cell line to then grow the what are
called organoids you can cause them to
different differentiate into a
particular organ that you are interested
in and so for instance in this case an
intestinal mucosal cell and then you can
actually then inject that cell with say
a microbial community that looks like
that comes from a human intestinal
sample and actually watch how that cell
interacts and so that would be another
example and one more that I can mention
is there's a huge growth area and
studying the human skin microbiome so
you can actually grow say keratinocytes
in cell culture and then how look at how
microorganisms grow on top of those
keratinocytes you can actually take that
cell culture of keratinocytes and
actually mimic sort of a scratch or a
wound and so you scratch that that that
cell culture plate and then there's no
cells there and you can actually watch
how the keratinocytes grow back together
and what role the skin microbiome plays
in that dr. fields we're gonna squeeze
in one more question do microbes and
biofilm react differently in
zero-gravity on IFS for example my my
guess is that that there would be some
differences and so I don't know I know
that there's a little bit in the
scientific literature of where folks
have taken some bacterial cultures on
Space Shuttle missions and onto the
International Space Station and they and
they've sort of tried to decide for how
the biological cell was responding to
that microgravity environment I don't
know if anyone has specifically done
that with biofilm and and certainly
poises a interesting question
thank you once again dr. Matthew fields
I would also like to thank our sponsor
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing until
December 7 2016 you will receive an
email from lab roots wedding you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's like that live event that's all
for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again bye